I managed to find a copy of Neil deGrasse
Tyson's PhD thesis.
And I spent all week trying to understand
it.
But it wasn't easy to read because it's 370
pages long.
And theses are not intended to be read by
anyone but experts on the subject.
So I became an expert on galaxies.
Obtaining a PhD is the highest academic qualification
for someone wanting to pursue a career in
science.
It's been a few years now since I left my
own PhD to pursue other things.
Looking at Tyson's success, I thought that
his career path might have been more of a
straight line to get to such a level.
So imagine my surprise when I read that this
thesis was not his first attempt at a PhD.
His line was indeed more squiggly.
He started as a graduate student at the University
of Texas, but felt that the expectation to
dedicate all of his time to research meant
that he had to give up his other interests
and the rest of who he was.
NDT: "And some of the advisors, some of the
other advisors, thinking they're doing me
a favour said, you know, you have this personality,
why don't you become a computer salesman.
I know some people who work for computers,
you could be-.
They're to try to do me a favour by getting
me out of their community.
I said to myself, if I'm going to have to
do a whole new PhD, it's not going to be at
this institution.
If it's got to be fresh, it will be fresh
in another place."
I wanted to read his thesis to see what kind
of scientific foundation he had before launching
himself into a career in science communication,
to see for myself his contributions to scientific
research, and to test myself to see if I stand
a chance of understanding any of it.
For his second attempt at a PhD this time
at Columbia University, Tyson took a stab
at understanding why the centre of our galaxy
is the way it is.
His thesis has the title, A Study of the Abundance
Distributions Along the Minor Axis of the
Galactic Bulge.
It was published in 1992, when he was 33.
A PhD thesis or dissertation is an account
of years of intense scientific research, and
it must contain an original contribution to
human knowledge.
So what was Tyson's?
Well, let's have a look.
Chapter one opens with the quote, "It is important
not to worship what is known, but to question
it".
Tyson then describes the galactic bulge as
a remarkable, compact zoo of stellar populations.
Let's draw a map of our galaxy the Milky Way.
This is a side-on view with many stars in
the spiral arms of the disk.
Around the Galactic Centre, there is a bulge
with a high concentration of stars, this is
Tyson's Zoo.
Perhaps the main attraction is a black hole
at the very centre, astronomers can peer in
at the black hole, our galaxy's fierce lion,
but only from afar.
There's a fear of being eaten if we ever got
too close, but the sun and therefore our solar
system and us are out here, nice and safe
held by the spiral arms.
Out there we have the halo comprised of older
stars and globular clusters, tightly bound
groups of many stars.
Here’s Tyson’s sketch of what he did,
which is that he looked into the galactic
bulge along seven different lines of sight
to understand the populations of stars in
the zoo and how they change as you get further
from the center.
The chosen lines of sight are low extinction
windows through the plane of the disk.
So he looked through sections of space where
there isn’t so much dust and gas in the
way to obscure the stars.
These are images of the seven windows and
you can notice the steep drop in star density
from the inner-most bulge to the outer-most
halo.
Each window is named with it’s latitude,
the smaller numbers are looking further out
towards the sparse halo.
Tyson measured properties of these stars like
their chemical abundance and velocities to
answer the following questions: What is the
abundance distribution function at different
galactic latitudes within the bulge?
Is there a smooth transition in abundance
between the bulge and the spheroid (halo)?
If not, at what latitude does the transition
occur?
And, was the bulge’s primordial gas used
completely in star formation or was it expelled
by ongoing supernova-driven winds?
To measure the chemical abundance of the stars,
Tyson used the Cerro Tololo Inter-american
Observatory located in Chile.
To get time observing on the telescope he
would have had to submit a proposal maybe
even a year in advance and compete against
all the other astronomers wanting a turn.
Then he had to hope that on his allocated
days, the sky wouldn’t be cloudy because
if it is, he wont see anything.
Chile was chosen to house many observatories
because it’s dry and with little light pollution,
but every observing run is still a roll of
the die.
Tyson’s first observing run was for one
night on the 7th of June 1989.
To get to the telescopes is a long drive up
a bumpy, scary road to an altitude of 2200m.
Up there the oxygen level is so low that you
might be out of breath just walking around.
So why would he go all that way just for one
night?
Perhaps he hoped to observe for longer but
got bad weather.
All I can tell from his thesis is that he
observed 4 fields of stars that night and
returned a year later for 2 more nights to
get the rest.
Tyson collected information about his stars
in the bulge and processed that data to find
their colours, temperatures, magnitudes and
also their chemical compositions.
He used the Washington photometric system
to measure certain wavelengths of starlight
and look for absorption lines.
These lines indicate that some of the light
that left the hot interior of the star, was
absorbed by atoms/ions in the star’s outer
atmosphere.
Some photons will be blocked from reaching
us and their absence reveals what elements
the stars are made of.
It’s not all smooth sailing though.
There are plenty of errors in every step of
the process to account for.
For Tyson these included overcrowding of stars
in his inner windows causing some of the light
profiles to overlap.
There was also the difficult job of removing
foreground stars from the images.
These both gave uncertainties in the final
measurements.
There are many pages of data, math and nuanced
details but Tyson eventually arrived at abundance
distributions which he said is the principal
focus of the study.
Doing science means making incremental changes
to models of how things work.
Tyson noted some existing models of how galaxies
chemically evolve and wanted to see if his
newly collected data from the bulge fit any
of these models.
The simplest model starts off with a ball
of gas, and all it can do is turn into stars.
No gas escapes.
This is called the Closed Box model, and if
you were to plot the metal content of stars
against the number of stars you would get
a plot shaped like this.
This is the abundance distribution.
In astronomy a metal is any element that's
not Hydrogen or Helium.
That’s not how chemists would define metals
but in astronomy it allows an easy distinction
between elements (H and He) that have existed
since the birth of the universe, and heavier
elements that must have been made by stars.
Stars make metals through nuclear fusion in
their cores or in supernova explosions.
Supernovae release metals back into the interstellar
medium, the space between the stars, from
which new stars with higher metallicities
may form.
A variant of the closed box is the leaky box
which allows some gas to escape into the rest
of the galaxy.
The abundance distribution for the leaky box
would be the same shape but shifted to the
left.
The stars have less metal in them on average
than stars in a closed box because those metal-rich
gas explosions from supernova are escaping.
So let’s take a look at Tyson’s abundance
distributions.
Here’s the first of his seven fields, the
one closest to the galactic center.
He measures metallicity as the ratio of Iron
to Hydrogen and says there is remarkable agreement
with the abundance distribution expected from
the simple model/closed box.
He fits a theoretical curve with a yield of
1.25 which is a measure of how much metal
is being returned to the interstellar medium.
This is scaled to the metallicity of the sun
so zero would be the sun and one is ten times
the sun’s abundance.
Going further from the center his next plot
has the same shape but shifted slightly to
the right.
The error bars are quite large and he says
this also fits the simple model but with a
higher yield.
The third plot moving further out again has
a higher average abundance but he concludes
that so far the region from the galactic center
to 0.75 kiloparsecs away is a well-mixed closed
box.
A parsec is a unit of distance but if you’re
more familiar with lightyears then this closed
box region is about 5000 lightyears across.
The next few fields show a shift to the left
and drop in average abundance.
We might be seeing that the box is leaking
or there's a more complicated process at hand.
But there are also not many stars being measured
here.
The last field, out in the halo, only has
3 stars!
This is them.
So he doesn’t really have a lot of statistics
on his side here.
Tyson’s measurements constitute the first
direct measurement of the galactic latitude
dependence of [Fe/H] in the galactic bulge.
He shows that it initially increases away
from the galactic center then steeply drops
off as you leave the bulge.
This drop off occurs around 1 kiloparsec away
from the center leading him to conclude that
those stars within 1 kiloparsec followed a
common evolution.
He also concludes that the inner bulge was
not significantly enriched by infall of gas
and that the inner bulge underwent no catastrophic
mass-loss from supernova-driven winds.
He finds that the inner bulge is chemically
distinct from the halo while the transition
region is a blending of the two.
Astrophysicists care about these questions
because any new information about the state
of our galaxy helps to refine all the models
which try to explain what our galaxy is and
how it got here.
Tyson talks about the implications of his
findings for models of how clouds of gas may
have collapsed to form our galaxy in the first
place.
There has been a lot more work done on galactic
evolution since this was written in the 90s.
Large scale surveys done by satellite and
ground based telescopes like GAIA and APOGEE
have been able to create maps of millions
of stars and dwarf the three data points Tyson
had in the halo.
Astronomy moves pretty fast since every year
there are upgraded tools and methods of observing.
This thesis wasn’t Tyson’s only contribution
to research, he has 13 research papers which
all will have contributed some new form of
understanding.
A few of his papers are taken from chapters
of this thesis and i’ll link those in the
description since the entire thesis as a whole
can only be found through the University of
Columbia.
His combined work has racked up a bit over
2000 citations, instances where other scientists
used it in some way.
Whilst this isn’t extremely high, it’s
pretty clear that Neil Degrasse Tyson’s
main contribution to science is not in his
research but in his work as a communicator.
His early research was his introduction to
all the key workings of the subject.
We can also take a look at his acknowledgments
page, he thanked the scientists who helped
them along the way.
He thanked his supervisor Mike Rich for his
encouragement and attention to scientific
detail and dedicated the work to his family.
He ended his thesis with a final thought.
I have lived and fulfilled a dream, yet my
life is just beginning.
Most of the notes I took and the facts I learned
about galaxies never made it to the screen
in this video.
But I really feel that for this week at least,
I did become an expert on galaxies.
Even though I might forget it all next week.
I found this thesis surprisingly good at covering
a base of topics that one would need going
forwards to work in astronomy or its communication.
And I suppose that's exactly the point of
a thesis.
But then success is all about what you do
from here.
This portion of the video is kindly sponsored
by Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of online classes, where members
come together to find inspiration and take
the next step in their creative journey.
For example, there is this excellent class
by Ali Abdaal covering video editing with
Final Cut Pro, the class can take you from
having no experience to editing great YouTube
videos.
Final Cut is the software that I use to edit
my videos.
And even though I've been doing it for a few
years now, I still learned a few new tips
and shortcuts from Ali's class.
Joining this class through Skillshare is also
much cheaper than many of the other expensive
editing courses out there.
In fact, it can be free for you there's a
special link down in the description in the
first 1000 people to click it will get a one
month free trial of Skillshare.
So thanks Skillshare for supporting my channel
and for helping people to try new things.
Also a thank you to my Patreon supporters,
including today's Patreon cat of the day Izzy.